Democrats getting another warning on how
their war on Maga will lead to a 2024
shacking JP Morgan boss Jamie Diamond
telling Joe Biden's party to knock off
the extreme divisive Maga crap I wish
the Democrats would think a little more
carefully when they talk about magga if
you look just take a step back be honest
he was kind of right about NATO kind of
R about immigration MH he grew the
economy quite well trus tax reform
worked he was right about some of China
but he wasn't wrong about some these
critical issues and that's why they're
voting for him and and I think people
should be a little more respectful of
our fellow citizens this negative talk
about magga is going to hurt Biden's
election campaign amen don't trash Trump
supporters and don't call them racist
but if liberals took that advice MSNBC
would turn into 24 hours of static and
that pundit who stole Trump's hairdo
wouldn't be able to smear half the
country it's a a Vengeance tour this
time around and that we talk about Trump
all the time we we also need to talk
about his voters as Tom Nichols writes
in the Atlantic these particular voters
want revenge as well they are getting
what they want because they too are set
on Revenge people didn't want to accept
that it's not economic anxiety it's
racial anxiety it's demographic Panic
All right but what happens when words
get turned into Deeds it looks like the
feds actually went after Maga supporters
house Republican of evidence that
Federal investigators asked Banks to
search customer transactions by using
terms like Maga and Trump as part of a
January 6th investigation isn't
everything part of that the government
even snooped on people who bought stuff
at Cabellas Bass Pro Shops Dicks
Sporting Goods the banks involved say
they were just following orders but Jim
Jordan says that this is a big problem
at the request of government you got
Banks searching private transactions of
their customers for key Search terms key
words it looks like without any warrants
without any legal process this is
financial surveillance at its
worst Dana again I have to blow the F's
horn we were sounding the alarm on this
kind of rhetoric three years ago we
predicted that that pushing this
divisive stuff you you're just going to
inevitably run out of victims right
you're going to end up with most of
America wondering why do these people
hate me well they've already been called
every name in the book for since eight
years right so there's the sunk cost
yeah you keep calling them that it just
goes in one ear and out out the other
nobody even cares anymore it's
meaningless at this point and without
hope then fear and
anger and hate are very powerful
motivators and I think that's what you
saw KLA Harris doing yesterday on The
View she's like I'm scared to death of
these crazies right she wants them to be
scared their voters to be scared I took
Jamie Diamond's comments as a couple of
signs one that the business Community
there in Davos is preparing for
president Trump to return to the White
House and also that the Biden campaign
is not listening to Jamie Diamond behind
the scenes and so he decided to say it
in public where it would get a ton of
attention and it leads the five and
that's what it's getting remember he
also contemplated running for president
and so I'm sure that the White House is
probably rolling their eyes but he's
making news and he's making a lot of
sense he was on Trump's business
diversity or business advisory not
diversity business Advisory Group and he
stayed on much longer than many of the
others remember Bob Iger High tailed it
quickly he stayed on at least till 2017
but just a couple weeks ago he made
headlines telling Democrats they should
vote for Haley because Trump would be so
bad so he's kind of all over the place
very transactional but his bottomline
message of treating people better is a
good one yeah let's listen to it how can
you argue Pier is always a pleasure to
have you visit to Charming little island
called England um we were talking about
this in the Green Room that you know you
know unless you kind of pump the brakes
on this kind of rhetoric it's only going
to get worse right and it's like but the
problem is as we show with Joy Reed if
it's your profit Center you know racial
divisive rhetoric what are you going to
do and for her to talk about crazies my
God the irony um I remember after 2016 I
was in New York and Trump won and it was
like a Ghost Town know everyone was in
sort of anaphylactic shock and I went to
the New York Knicks the next next night
with my son and by chance Chris Rock was
at next door table and we got talking
and I said what do you make of the
election he said it's whatever whatever
and then I said why why do you think
Trump won and Hillary lost he went you
know why he said because if someone's
killed eight people don't go around
constantly saying he's killed nine I
thought it was a very smart observation
in other words as we would say in
England don't EG the s you don't need to
there's enough stuff you can go out with
Trump which is completely legitimate and
accurate and that's fine but for 8 years
now there's been this constant barrage
of wild OV exaggeration whether it's the
Russia collusion whether it's the the
new Hitler blah blah blah blah blah and
I was really impressed by Jamie Dam I
thought it a really smart take to remind
people that not only are they not crazy
a lot of trump supporters but they have
legitimate reasons to think that Trump
would do a better job than Joe Biden
running the country and he listed a
number of things that Trump achieved
last time and you know this took me back
to what Hillary Clinton said about the
bastard of deplorables right if you
start branding all Trump supporters 80
million Americans as deplorable or crazy
it's going to come back and bite you and
I think they are raging hysterically and
with wild exaggeration right into
Trump's hands yeah that's true turning
him into a folk hero which we said here
judge okay so all this branding has now
turned into the tracking of purchase
Decisions by the government how do you
how is this possible what's your legal
take on this well my legal take is that
it's a Fourth Amendment violation and
the other day I spoke with the fact that
the Biden Administration is before The
Supreme Court on the merthy versus
Missouri case where the Supreme where
the Supreme Court will decide as the
lower courts have already decided
whether or not the Biden Administration
in in in interfered with free freedom of
speech the first amendment by forcing
some of the social media companies
whether it's Facebook or YouTube or X to
only promote X then I say that not
meaning X but to only promote one
concept as opposed to another and
suppressing conservative speech now
you've got the Democrats who are openly
violating the Fourth Amendment you know
they hate the Second Amendment because
it was Obama who said you know those
Republicans they cling to God and guns
or religion and guns so you know the
amazing thing is that they will turn
around and say you know Donald Trump is
a threat to democracy but we're taking
away your first amendment we want to
take away your second we're interfering
with the Fourth Amendment search and
seizure and now it's not just Trump
they're going after every one of us
every one of us is as Hillary said part
of the deplorables and Joy Reed I mean I
don't even want to mention her name but
she says that that we want revenge that
the followers of Donald Trump want want
revenge just like Americans in the 30s
wanted fascism I mean where is she
getting this stuff from their job is to
divide us to hate us to call us names
and use apocalyptic terms but this is
where they lose Donald Trump was
President for four years and we still
have a country we had a great Economic
Policy asked a Democrat Jamie Diamond he
was right on immigration he was right on
tax reform and he was right on NATO
that's what that that's what Jamie
Diamond said so you know they're just
doing this to their to their loss in the
end Jesse um looking at how they're
targeting people like you and I'm
thinking isn't it time to start
operating your life under the radar
maybe consider changing your identity
instead of shopping at a Bass Pro Shop
going to vegan bakeries ident why don't
you you should identify as a Democrat a
nonbinary Democrat just to put him off
your scent how would that affect my two
shows I think it would make it better
you think so yes yes it can't be any
worse I think Jessica Waters is bring to
it I'm
Waters and I am a
girl I think Dana is right we're
witnessing Trump repair his relationship
with the business Community remember
that soured after the Tillerson firing
the Chinese trade War and the fine
people hoax but all of these Executives
in Wall Street they live on the coast
and they live in the cities and they
can't help not notice the destruction
that these Democrat policies have had
with the migration the crime the remote
work and money sees around the corner
and they see Trump sliding into first
place and they saw the signal he sent at
the fox town hall and at his victory
speech in Iowa and that was I'm going to
laser focus on policy I am going to work
with Democrats to clean up the cities
I'm not going to have time for
Retribution because we're going to be
having so much success and success is
the best form of Revenge and they see
that and they like that and that's a
winning message Clean Cities secure the
Border cheap energy no Wars working
together if he sticks in a disciplined
way to that there's no way he loses this
election now Joy read Greg you know how
I detest Cable News hosts making broad
sweeping generalizations about Dem
traffic groups she does not speak for
White America Pete Heth speaks for White
America the guy's been in every Suburban
Diner in this country and I don't think
she's ever been to a Suburban Diner has
she been to Iowa Joy Reed's at her desk
in Manhattan every day of the week the
only time she sees aaga Republicans
probably when she walks into NBC News
headquarters and passes the security
guard this country cannot have an
election where one side is demonized and
you don't say how I've improved your
life and Joe Biden he kind of has to
demonize because if you look at the
metrics he has not improved anyone's
life and if you want to see how the
demonization is going Trump is now more
popular post Jan 6 than before Jan 6 cuz
they overplayed their hand they uh
overid the sule the overg the nobody
wants a fluffy sufa yes that's eism okay
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
Subs subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else